ladies and gentlemen as a notorious
optimist I normally follow the good old
Monty Python rule to always look on the
bright side of life but as we talk about
global media this is not always as easy
quality journalism is becoming
increasingly difficult to implement
sometimes that's due to a lack of
knowledge about the standards of the
craft but frequently the reasons behind
journalistic impoverishment are
political freedom of the press and
freedom of expression are under huge
pressure in many countries for
journalists it becomes increasingly
dangerous to investigate report in short
to speak the truth
more and more colleagues are paying with
their lives for exercising their job and
this human right freedom of information
is also steadily being eroded people are
prevented from accessing independent
information site blocking and censorship
are sad realities in many countries
international broadcasters controlled by
non-democratic regimes are ramping up at
the same time we are witnessing a
renaissance of cynical propaganda
disinformation and media aggregation as
the older generations among us might
recall from Cold War days ladies and
gentlemen
sadly an overwhelming majority of the
world's population lives without a free
press without free access to information
without the right to freedom of opinion
prosperity has grown freedom
unfortunately hasn't so after all these
sad news how do we respond to that
throughout the world the struggle for
freedom of expression has grown tougher
as a democratic nation in the heart of
Europe we want European values to be
more widely perceptible the launch of
our English TV service is an important
step in that direction
ladies and gentlemen like you I'm
looking forward to an interesting
congress too
meet interesting people and discuss
fascinating topics and I wish you good
debates many new ideas and also a lot of
fun with a global media forum thank you
democracy democratization of the digital
arena the imposition of fundamental
democratic rights in the internet from
my point of view that is the fundamental
political challenge in our digital age
values we think are constitutive for our
democracy in the analog world have to be
won't preserve in the digital world and
have to be defended there and this
results in a political and also cultural
and media policy task many don't have
enough people ladies and gentlemen the
most important instances of democratic
control are the independent media this
is why media quality and diversity are
essential in the digital age and luckily
their media companies director-general's
etc who search for rules with or they
might in order to maintain quality of
diversity in the media and to safeguard
the freedom of the press in the world
dieter village makes a very important
contribution has made a contribution for
more than 60 years and against the
backdrop of the large number of crises
and in spite of massive russian
non-information in the Baltic state the
work of Deutsche Welle is more important
than ever before see if you mind we are
lucky to have you touchable represents
freedom of the press human rights
democracy
and last but not least it represents of
a activist the social societal model
that is
so attractive there deserves as an
annotation for any market economy it's
an ambassador of our democratic rule of
law particularly in regions of crisis
and in states that are governance we
define an auditor in way it's like a
link to the free world for many people
Xena on that note ladies and gentlemen I
wish you love excess forever friends
conference and a little consensus are
lots of debates with results and
findings on foreign policy and
international democracy in digit in the
digital age thank you very much good
morning ladies and gentlemen as we all
know Deutsche Welle DW is an institution
for public service broadcasting and on
this basis its key performing elements
are independent journalism and a
determined focus on quality program from
now on these ambitious commitments are
also expressed with a new clip that you
can read behind me on my on the wall
made for minds I think that this claim
is one of the best that has been created
so far in the German in our German media
industry and it is certainly the best to
underline the genuine duties of public
service broadcasting namely to address
the minds of the audience and not the
cheapest and lowest common denominator
of mass entertainment there is
absolutely nothing to say against mass
entertainment this is an natural and
legitimate function of a free media
market but this is not the job of public
service generation or broadcasting
public service broadcasting has the
unique privilege of
being financed by public fees and in
return it has to create a sustainable
programming for information culture and
education I think that the W Dolce Bella
fulfills this commitment with its
current programming and especially now
with this enhanced programming better
then most of the other colleagues of
Public Service television the W dot
Vella is a well managed modern media
company saw the solidly financed and so
I tell to the management and to the
journalists and the editors of Deutsche
Welle
there are no more excuses now you have
to perform your program in a quality
that matches your great claim made
formats and I wish you all the best for
this important job
or psyche or coupler the pressures on
public broadcasting after that the
measure up in this international age
director-general Limburg it's almost
time
CW News live from Berlin it's the day of
reckoning for Greece can athens reach a
deal with its creditors while Greeks
rally in the capital ahead of an
emergency summit of eurozone leaders DW
live from Berlin the new DW news
programme well done
DW and all the best in the future a big
hand as well for Commissioner Monica
butas director-general peter lindbergh
for answering our questions and talking
to us today well it's time to hand over
now to my anchor colleague Christopher
spring gate who's been working on a very
big topic that's going to play a central
role at this global media forum he'll be
guiding you through the next segment
starting with that age-old question when
it bleeds it leads
Christopher it's an incredible claim
when it bleeds it leads difficult for
many of us it seems it's bleeding more
now than ever before is that claim still
justified well I think it is I mean this
is what we're going to be discussing
with my panelists which I'll be
introducing in a short while I think it
probably is still valid as long as our
coverage is balanced as long as our
coverage is accurate and particularly
important as long as our coverage is
representative of reality there are many
realities in this room ladies and
gentlemen if it bleeds it leads
foreign policy and international crisis
reporting that is now the issue at hand
you can see the four my panelists some
of the chairs and tables are being put
together let me just point to this young
gentleman over there his name is Yakov
Leon and you see he has his laptop open
he is reading your tweets please do take
your seats I think we all have some
water your microphones are there
Rick Richards phones ring I did tell you
he's very senior at BBC so know it if it
bleeds it leads is that still a valid
way for the best way of selecting
international news well it's a very
simplified way of describing the issue
for what is a very complicated
increasingly complicated world so I kind
of think they're short if you want a
simple short answer to a very simple
question it's no but maybe I should
expand upon that a bit I do think that I
mean of course there is you know there's
always being truth in in the line and
and when you simplify things in that way
it's always based on on some element of
truth but I don't think that I don't
think it's anything like as simple as
that I think that that for me implies
somehow other than what we do is simply
about ratings about that that is above
everything that the first thing we must
do is get the the greatest number of
people to watch and a greater number of
people than somebody else and I don't
actually think that's the motivation
certainly not the motivation for what we
do in the BBC but as I say we are an
increasingly complicated world
complicated because of the stories we
cover big globalized stories where it
seems that every big issue stretches way
beyond the borders of the of the story
itself where it starts from and I think
that poses a challenge for us
complicated by all the things we've
heard about so far this morning in terms
of the way that the media is changing
that the fact that the audience is as
capable of producing news as all of the
media organizations themselves Richard
so in other words if it's if it bleeds
it leads
still valid but one of many criterias
what I what I get out of that in a very
complex well I'd like to bring in Anika
what is it one of the decision-making
structures at the EBU do you lead on the
bleeding well we represent organizations
like the BBC and and chabela we
represent 74 media
sessions mainly public service across 56
countries so it covers quite a large
proportion of the media organization
that effect Europe we don't we don't
choose the stories ourselves they're
chosen for by the organizations that we
represent so yes there is an editorial
choice and there is an editorial part of
what we are doing in EBU but we are not
producing mainly for but you do see the
choosing that other people are doing
why do what do they use to go don't use
we do every day and I my simple answer
to this question would also be exactly
the same as the BBC's know let me let me
ask Katrin at this point you're often
where it's bleeding does that mean you
have no problems getting your stories at
the top of the news and and do you think
that's right well I think sometimes it
is right sometimes it's not so I would
say yes and no to this you know sentence
when it bleeds it leads
if you take the conflicts today's
conflicts that's the best example you
could give I mean there's a lot of
coverage of you know the crisis in
Ukraine for example where as you know
some of the conflicts are becoming so
dangerous and so bloody that there is no
more coverage at all and that might not
just be an editorial decision I would
say you know that's you know something
that is the result of the fact that the
world is coming more becoming more and
more complicated and you know if you ask
me it's becoming more and more dangerous
so yes some conflict stories some you
know tragic events some natural
disasters you know would always lead the
news if they happen or in most of the
parts of the world when it comes to
armed conflict we didn't have reporters
in Moscow or not only German media I
think most of the world media didn't
have reporters in Mosul or places like
Rocco we don't really know what's going
on you know and this is
a state in the so-called Islamic state
we don't actually know what you know the
people of - are thinking and you know
why people would be joining them all
these are unanswered questions I mean
and there's certainly no doubt that the
conflict in Syria is a very very bloody
one and it doesn't really get coverage
okay thank you for that country let me
bring in andreas at this point Catherine
you're sort of a contrast in a sense to
Katrina Katrina being sort of at the
sharp end of many conflicts you're at
the diplomatic end in Geneva or in New
York where the UN is discussing these
issues do you find that if it bleeds it
leads gets in the way of your what
you're trying to inform us about a
little bit take on Richards first
remarks because I think he painted a too
positive picture which might be true for
the BBC or at least for some the
programs of the BBC but it's not true
for the whole global media reality I
think we do have a red race which is a
red race among competing media
especially the electronic media to a
lesser degree the print media and the
issue is who is first with the most
spectacular news and the most
spectacular news are mostly violent
conflict blood etc and that makes it
much more difficult for journalists who
cover the very very dreadful often
efforts to maybe deescalate or even
solve a conflict and diplomatic level to
get into the news I think the the the
rat-race is not unfortunately about who
delivers the best analysis the best
in-depth information and the best
enlightenment for for the people one of
the most striking examples for me was
the reporting about the Egyptian
Arab Spring for three weeks in a row we
had every night impressive pictures from
the Tahrir Square in Cairo with 300,000
people demonstrating and some young
Egyptians being able in perfect English
to explain to us in 10 sentences about
what it was all about and then Mubarak
was gone and five weeks later elections
and every
body was not only surprised but shocked
that the Muslim Brotherhood Vince 47%
and the more radical Salafist Union
another 26% which is all together to
serve majority why were we all surprised
because nobody went outside the center
of Cairo in these three weeks you could
have learned already by going to the
slums of Cairo or by going further into
the countryside that people are much
more conservative politically
religiously culturally and they're the
Muslim Brotherhood got 90% in some
districts yeah so we all go and some
similar happened with us all of us
covering what happened on there on the
Maidan in january/february less last
year nobody went out to the east at this
time trying to sense I'll go to the
people in the eastern parts of Ukraine
think about all this we only did it when
the war started there I am so I think we
have huge problems and we should devote
some time of our discussion about how we
get out of that whether there is a
possibility in the context of the
technological realities Richard
described whether there is a possibility
my answer is yes but I think we should
discuss it later
max you what andreas was saying there
you know we're in Cairo
we're in Kiev but we're not looking
beyond the capitals is that something
that that you've experienced as well
you've been in Washington you're in
Brussels Berlin are we too focused on
these capitals well I can say for Europe
in the u.s. we did go beyond the
capitals definitely even I mean in the
u.s. that was probably most of what
we're doing it depends on axis you know
the question is where do you have the
most access as a foreign correspondent
as a german foreign correspondent for
example in the u.s you don't really have
that much much access at the White House
even the German correspondents of who
sit at the White House press conference
every day they don't get an interview
with Obama because the politicians there
and especially the White House says okay
what's in it for us so you go beyond the
Capitol you try to tell the stories
about gun control about
about abortion and talk to the people
for that it's a fantastic country here
in Europe it's a different story in
Brussels you have a lot of access to
decision-makers so you try to cover that
more and then of course there's the
security situation also I mean I know
all the stories and Catharine obvious
knows that a lot better than I do in
Baghdad most of the journalists they
just sit in their hotels and they have
the stringers in the cameramen who go
out the Iraqis who go out there and do
it and do the actual work so it's a
security question as well for Europe I
would say no you know you know we're not
just in the capitals we go out of the
capitals in the US that was true too but
I would like to add something to what
andreas said earlier because I had the
initial at the same initial reaction to
what Richard said in the beginning and
in my head it was like yeah sure BBC you
can do that you know you can ignore
things which you don't I think so but
it's not a story like Charlie Hebdo for
example or Germanwings obviously the BBC
is there too but I do agree especially
if you work for Life TV these days you
have to be there fast because that's for
some people especially the younger
generations that's the main reason why
they are still watching TV if you're
there with a live satellite connection
then that's the moment and something is
actually happening at that moment that's
the moment where most people watch
because that's where they get the the
fastest reaction to what's happened even
faster maybe than Twitter or the more
complete picture that's why people still
asila watching live sports for example
why that's a stronghold of TV so I do
believe as a live TV station you have to
be there you have to try to be there
quick especially in those cases the
question is what do you do then do you
just describe you know what you're
seeing same thing over and over again or
do you really try to put it into context
paint a bigger picture what is the
source of that conflict so I don't think
it's bad to be there as fast as possible
but what you do then counts let me just
put some punctuation here yeah cough lay
on is telling me that we have some
tweets can I borrow your microphone for
a second Richard and we'll give it to
Jakov what are people tweeting into this
discussion
well let's start with some really good
news a global media forum is among top
10 most discussed topics on Twitter in
this very moment it's at number 2 in
Germany there's a lot of interesting
twists and posts we have read at least
thousand I think so far and here just a
few virtual represent human rights
democracy and rule of law then global
media forum taking place in old
Parliament building we all feel like
lawmakers apparently a lot of people on
social media were quite excited because
the red button we have here in the
plenary Hall and because of the lunch of
Deutsche Welle TV channel in English
lots of pictures here's one quite
entertaining tweet another normal day in
the former Bundestag but there's a big
red button the temptation to run and
push his high or global media forum is
like a rock concert but for media types
referring to the panel discussion
Miranda Sharma is asking our journalists
obsessed with violence and gore
Olga also tweeted an interesting
question how to deal with propaganda
fake news in Germany referring to
Russian media Gary if it bleeds it leads
is justified as long as the coverage is
representative of reality our role in
creating solutions question mark another
interesting thoughts what do we do with
audiences who only look for the blood in
the news
no viewers no money okay thank you yeah
cough people are complaining they can't
find you on twitter andreas you're not
on Twitter they're looking for your
Twitter handle I don't have a Twitter
follower yet and I don't intend to the
gentleman who has the microphone thank
you for being patient where are you from
okay thanks very much my name is fheo am
a Nigerian currently working and living
in Tanzania over the years its Africans
have felt very misrepresented and
misreported by the international media I
mean even if you go to journalism school
that's one of the first things that
you're told to people dying about in a
bomb blast in
somewhere in Nigeria and it's big news
and yet people are dying every day
hundreds of people are dying every day
so how do we make a choice and how do we
decide on what needs to be reported okay
I'd like to respond I very much agree
with your analysis in your first
sentence that Africa is probably the by
far most under represented under covered
part of the world in the media you can
only change that by making an
intentional decision to change it the
little paper I am working for the tiger
site on Berlin made this decision ten
years ago we have approximately 50%
sometimes even more of our whole phone
app or reporting devoted to the
continent of Africa we have a lot of
correspondents they are not all fully
employed because we don't have the money
but stringers etc more than any other
print media and any other electronic
media in Germany and but this is an
intentional decision your colleagues who
cover Asia who cover the United Nations
who cover North America have to agree to
because they get much less space I would
dream that torture whether with limited
resources it does have compared to the
other big players maybe makes a similar
conscious decision to devote much more
coverage to the African continent then
let's say to Washington or the other
familiar places max Hoffman the expert
on our Africa program because I'm in
Brussels but I know that we have made
exactly that decision with the arrival
of our new general manager Peter
Lindbergh and we do have a studio now in
Nigeria by the way we have my producer
stringers we work with a lot of beter
journalists because we have come to the
same conclusion in is for a news channel
that is broadcast in Africa and that has
a lot of success actually by many
standards in Africa it was a necessity
to do that so we did yes and we've just
also signed up
Edith Kimani who's our new correspondent
in Nairobi in Kenya she by the way
Andrea
130,000 followers on Twitter Anika
you wanted to just come in and say I
don't know why we continued sort of
discussing this as if there wasn't
anybody doing something about it
Denmark is a small country dr is not the
BBC does not have the resources of the
BBC it's a small outlet after all and
they have had fantastic
you know results with doing this and
mind you constructive news is not
telling just a positive story it is
actually trying to go one step ahead and
do something and show the solutions and
maybe it's a small one so you know there
are solutions there are people who are
trying to change what we are now talking
about I can just add at this point you
you may remember in January this year
Arianna Huffington sent an email to all
of her staff they have a new relatively
new column which is called what's
working and in that email Arianna
Huffington said we want to show that the
era of if it bleeds it leads is over by
relentlessly telling the stories of
people in communities doing amazing
things these are the stories our readers
are most interested in reading and
sharing ah the established media losing
audience and I'm talking about
newspapers I'm talking about the evening
news my son will walk out the room when
the evening news comes up are we losing
audience that kind of audience the
audience of the future because we are
only covering doom and disaster max I
don't think so by the way I still say we
don't only cover doom a disaster I'd
like to maintain that the complaints of
the newspapers that they're losing
people because they don't print as many
newspapers anymore I don't think that
means that the audience necessarily
disagrees with what the newspaper prints
I just think it's not up to date how
people read their newspapers anymore if
it's a good and important story if it's
well researched the journalist knows
what he's talking about and you could
put it in a modern form digital eyes on
a smartphone you know if it's right
there you
have you use social media to park then
it's still it's just as relevant as it
was the point is though that it's harder
today because there's just so much
competition out there thank you ladies
and gentlemen we're going to wrap up at
this on that note thank you very much
for your attention I'm gonna hand over
back now to Brian Thomas who'll just
give you a few important bits of
information before you so much
Christopher a couple great questions
coming up there very much thanks very
much you are our panel